我和我父母的关系一直都还不错，嗯，我是二二年办的婚礼结的婚。嗯，从这个婚礼开始，呃，我和我母亲的关系就不那么融洽了，因为我没有办法再继续忍耐下去了啊。因为从小到大呢，嗯，我父母是很少啊，关照我就是那种他在身边照顾我呢啊，一直一直在姥姥爷家啊，各种亲戚家这样的生活啊，其中有一个舅舅啊，我们中间就发生了一些在我初中的时候，然后这件事情在我成年之后，我跟我母亲说了。然后我妈说，嗯，那个那以后你爸知道了怎么办呢？你姥爷知他们怎么办呢？我们的关系以后怎么办呢？然后当时我二十几岁，我觉得他是很有道理，可是到我30多岁结婚的时候，我不想让这个舅舅来参加我的婚礼啊，因为您的直播我也听了很多啊。我觉得我这样这已经是我的底线了吧。但是我妈妈就是很委屈，然后不停的给我发微信。
让他们来吗？让他们来嘛，你快说呀，你快说呀，在我的我，我没有回复，但是在我的理解里，他这就是在逼我回答。这样子，所以，所以我我觉得我和我妈妈的关系从那个时候开始，我就没有办法面对中间发生了很多，还有很多很多的事情，但是这个是最后最后一根稻草，就是这个。
嗯，现在我和我妈妈呢，就是我现在和我父母基本上是不会电话沟通的啊，只有呃每到逢年过节的时候，我老公放假的时候，我老公带我回去，然后我老公就处理这些和我父母的关系。所以我想，但是我如果不跟他们联系的话，我就会心里感生内疚，我觉得我对不起他们，因为我作为农村一个独生女来讲，他们也有供我念书，供我读到大学。然后我去年生病的时候也给了我一些钱。所以我应该怎么处理和他们的关系呢？该发疯就发疯，发这一次疯，把这个心结打开，发这一次疯，把这个问题就捅破了，就跟你妈就吵，我就捅破了这件事情对我的伤害有多大，这件事情对我的人生影响有多大？你们没有站在我的立场上为我考虑，没有好好的保护我，没有好好的维护我。你们这件事情就是做错了，在发疯的时候就发疯，发过这一次疯了之后，捅破了之后，脓疮捅破了之后，以后的日子照常过。如果他能够对吧，就能够感受到自己女儿的那种痛苦，她能够看到你发疯的那个样子，她能够心疼你，以后咱就还还是能以母女相处，如果他不能，那就别处了。
啊，你就就该发疯的时候就一定要彻彻底底底的发一次疯，就在你妈妈面前直接发疯。就你和你妈两个人在一个房间，关上门，给我反锁门，就在这个房间里面，该哭哭，该发疯发疯。让他彻彻彻底底的切实的感受到这件事情对你的伤痛，让他感受到如果以后他再提再提什么，让你去见舅舅，再提什么舅舅要来，你参加你什么这孩子满月宴，这那的，你如果以后他再提的话，少来往。
不要很内疚，我跟我跟他发疯过。我有段时间我觉得我自己挺精神病的，就是我是八六年的，我30岁左右的时候，我给他一边打电话，我在上班的时候，我一边打电话，在那边打，打完电话哭，哭完之后，我马上就要擦干眼泪回去。我做销售嘛，我要我要对付，要应祝客户，我觉得没有用这件事情，那时候我还没有结婚，然后结婚的时候他还这么逼我。然后这件事情我就已经已经不想再跟他联系了。最让我绝望的是，我婚礼结束之后。
然后我妈妈用特别骄傲的语气跟我说，你接我孩子，你舅家孩子都随礼了，你人没大把钱都烧了呢。现在特别想骂你，真的，我不知道我应该怎么跟我妈沟通。我20岁的时候遇到流氓，我妈说我，我回去特别害怕，我跟我妈说，我妈说你怎么能这么，你怎么啊？你怎么能这么想呢？那人家不是喜欢你吗？你以后这样的话，你还怎么搞对象？所以我觉得我妈妈是不是想法有问题？我应该多理解她，多包容她。我就每天都在这样纠结。那你特别适合去看一个电视剧，这个电视剧叫玫瑰的故事。
玫瑰的故事里面有一个女孩的经历啊，跟你就特别特别她那个经历是被继父欺负，然后她的妈妈一直都是属于那种呃从来不维护她，从来不保护她。然后这个女孩儿她自己非常的努力，在北京啊，做到了艺术品这个行业里面的这个顶尖的这么一个总监的位置。然后她也找了一个相对来说条件比较好的男生，他们结婚，她的公公婆婆对她也特别的好。她往后余生的生活，只要她跟她妈妈做了切割之后，他的生活就是特别幸福美满的。你一定要去看这个电视剧，一定要去学会比苏苏更坚强。那个主角的名字就叫苏苏，你一定要比他更坚强更决绝。你早一天跟你的妈妈在情感上剪断这个脐带，你就早一天幸福，早一天少少了很多的那个纠结、美好和痛苦。
其实，我当时看电视剧的时候啊，因为龙飞是我特别容易带入。我当时看电视剧的时候，就如果我是苏苏，我不可能跟这个妈妈再有什么来往，我不可能再给这个妈妈一分钱。我也不可能，我不可能除非说法律判我，法律判我说一个月给800好，我尊重法律，我一个月给你打800，但是你想来参加我的婚礼，抱歉，我不会告诉你婚礼在哪里举行，你想来参与我的生活，抱歉。我不会告诉你我的工作单位在哪里，你想来跟我亲近，抱歉，我会明确的跟我的丈夫说明白，我和我妈妈之间的关系是决裂的关系，你不要对我妈妈有什么好脸色。我的人生是由我做主的，我爱你，我愿意嫁给你，是我能够决定的事情，我的妈妈决定不了我人生的任何一毛钱的事情，所以你不需要去讨好我的妈妈，你也不需要对我的妈妈有什么礼貌，有什么客套，什么都不需要。我会早早的跟我的老公讲清楚这个事情的，否则的话，以后你的老公他想要成为一个好老公，他就不得不对你的妈妈去尊重去客套。他越对你的妈妈尊重客套，越对你的妈妈千依百顺，你就越纠结越痛苦，还不如你自己说明白，然后老同学，你说我是1986年，然后我老公。
是1994年的，嗯，我们两个20年认识的，然后22年结的婚啊，现在已经结婚两年了。然后我老公呢，嗯，对我很好，嗯，一年生病的时候，呃，我病的很重。然后我老公呢，就是竟然比结婚之前对我还要好。但是我现在的问题就在于我没有办法心安理得的享受他对我的好，有这个事情啊，他对你好，你心里明白，那你也要对他好，你要学会给他安全感，你要学会去表达自己。我跟你说，这事特别重要，没事儿的时候就跟你老公抱着，就说。
老公，我觉得这个世界上，你是和我最亲的人，你是我唯一的依靠。除了你之外，没有人值得我依靠，没有人值得我信任。说说还吧啦吧啦掉眼泪，特别增进夫妻的感情，特别能够给男人安全感，给男人成就感，这一点非常重要。你一定要听龙飞姐的，就是你感受到他对你的爱，感受到他对你的温暖的时候，一定要第一时间就抱住他，就跟他说，就抱住他就跟他说，你心里面的那种对他的那种感动、感激甚至感恩，一定要说出来。我告诉你，很关键啊，嗯，就是现在我们两个结婚两年了，还没有要孩子的这个决定，然后我也想嗯，跟您问一下，我就是我怎么样才能做出一个就是心甘情愿的这样一个决定，就是生孩子还是不生孩子呢这个事儿啊，龙飞龙飞姐呢，我自己有了孩子。首先第一点，我不会盲目的去劝大家都生孩子，我也不会盲目的跟大家说生孩子这个过程当中女人要付出多少，怎么怎么地的。我告诉你，生孩子这个事情一定是你自己心中有足够多的爱，你心里面蓄积了足够多的温暖，足够多的爱。
你确信你自己有这个能力去爱一个新的生命，去给予别人无条件的爱的时候，女生或者说你特别想，就如果说我这辈子没有得到爸爸妈妈给我足够多的爱，但是我特别希望自己能够成为那个可以给另外一个人足够多的爱的人。你也可以生活明白吗？我觉得我有时候我内心的想法真的是过于呢，我去年因为生病嘛，我到医院查了很多，我也没有查出什么病因，没有实质性的病症，但是我也没去检查什么抑郁症，什么的我我现在我关于生不生孩子的事情，我老公也非常尊重我的决定。然后因为结婚的时候那年我发着疯，所以现在他们也不管我生不生孩子的这件事情，就是我，我有时候会想，我身边还有一个孩子，蹦蹦跳跳的，这样的话也很可爱，我也会感觉很幸福。但是我更多的时间都会时候，特别因为我觉得我家的基因应该断死去了，不能这么想问题哇，这么想问题逻辑是不对的，你知道为什么吗？我们之所以痛苦，其实是因为我们内心。
追求渴望，渴望一些东西，我们才会痛苦。我们如果从我们的父辈母辈那里看到了他们的生命的缺陷，我们存在的意义是什么？对于我们自己来说，就是我如何成为一个可以戒掉父母身上那些缺陷的一个人。这是我们人生当中最重要的一个课题。我今天讲的有点哲学了啊，人生当中最重要的一个课题就是我出生了，我观察了周遭的人和事，我发现他们身上有好有坏。然后我自己如何修炼才能够成为那个，比如说，爸爸身上有什么缺点，我不想成为那样的人，妈妈身上有什么缺点，我不想成为那样的人。我如何修炼自己，才能把我自己从原生家庭，从爸爸妈妈那个模具里面给脱离出来，然后重新给自己塑造一个样子。
这个才是人生最重要的最终极的一个目标，从爸爸妈妈那里脱离出来的时候，我们这个人并没有完全的定型。后续需要我们不断的修剪身上的这些呃不好的，突出的这些疙疙瘩瘩的东西，需要我们不断的去磨它修剪它，然后把自己磨成一个自己喜欢的样子，我们的人生就圆满了。
明白吗？谢谢，谢谢菲丽，谢谢，一定要去看啊，一定要比玫瑰的故事里面的苏苏更坚强，更决绝，更杀伐决断，你就能够拥有美好的人生。并且给我送礼物的姐妹们啊，就是在在龙飞姐的直播间，不是不用送礼物啊，省着点钱花，有钱咱也省着点花啊。有的时候，嗯，我自己会觉得我的这份工作。
真的很有价值，很有意义，同意吗？因为我在治愈你们的时候，反过来也在治愈自己，就相互的相互的救赎。有的时候在治愈自己的粉丝，反过来也会治愈到我自己。因为龙飞姐从小长这么大，嗯，也经历过很多不好的事情，什么鬼样就是各种骚扰啊，各种各样的事情，就也经历过很多很多不好的事情。但是我现在的生活非常的幸福。
就是我的先生，嗯，就是各种现在跟我各种亲密的关系，我们非常过得非常非常的幸福。所以呢，龙飞也希望嗯，跟我相同类似从小长大的过程当中遭遇过伤害，遭遇过不幸，遭遇过这些欺负的人，你们看到龙飞律师就会看到一个模板，我们也可以很幸福。我我觉得我现在好像是激素水平的问题，我以前好像没有那么爱哭。